all right y'all before we go I want to
share one last Feelgood story this is
what I'm
[Music]
liking a Missouri woman has developed
Innovative hair extensions that are
designed to prevent scalp and skin
irritation uh the extensions are made of
banana fiber so they don't just feel
better but they're also environmentally
friendly and biodegradable as well super
cool we have the Creator on the line
right now watching on Fox 2 in St Louis
from rebundle say hi to see
everybody hi Kelly what's up Sierra
thank you for joining us first of all
thank you for having me absolutely so
this started after you had issues with
your own extensions right yeah that's
right so a few years ago I was suffering
from scalp irritation while wearing
braids and grew concerned about the
impact plastic hair was having on my
scalp and the environment so I didn't
then started to research and learned
that one in three black women like
myself will experience scalp irritation
while wearing braids due to the toxins I
immediately knew I needed to find an
alternative and what I loved about
banana fiber is its likeness to hair and
it's one of the top growing crops in the
world so there's no shortage of material
oh wow that's incredible so how does it
work so we actually start with the stem
of the tree or the trunk of the banana
tree we feed the fiber into an extractor
that removes all the gummy materials and
impurities it then has to be texturized
and dyed detangled Etc so that that full
process takes about 8 hours hours to get
to this finished product we box it in
these beautiful orange boxes and ship
them across the US and the UK and what
our customers love other than the fact
that it's itch-free and non-toxic is
that they can be reused up to three
times and it's also made with
biodegradable ingredients that is so
cool man what a what a very
cool Innovative thing to do like you're
so smart thank you so much s for joining
us and just turning everybody on to this
and also I'm liking your post right now
thank you and also that's not all our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
precise the go-to pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show want to honor truly
Unstoppable people just like you ma'am
so they're going to give you $1,000 just
for being
rad thank you thank you so much thank
you and thank you to all of our guests
this hour Mato Lopez Jeffrey Roan Matt
Matthews and Michael y'all have a great
day if it's not TR change
it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home